okay I'm back and we're gonna answer the
question how long should a person fast
for okay so let's talk about this
ideally you want to ease into this
gradually because you want to let your
body fully adapt the goal is to run your
body on fat-burning and do keto at the
same time you're doing intermittent
fasting so you start with 12 hours which
is not too hard and then you go to 18
and let your body get used to it and
then 20 hours okay and then you're
eating window is about 4 hours a lot of
people are doing this right here
including myself this is a really good
range and one thing I like about this is
that with 2 meals you can really easily
get most of your nutrient requirements a
bunch of people also doing one meal a
day they're doing 23 hours they'll eat
and then they'll wait another 23 hours
ok if they eat in one hour and this is
also effective and the amount of
nutrient requirements are not near as
when you're doing 3 meals or even two
meals so you actually can recycle all
these nutrients and proteins so this is
fine as well
but you just have to kind of graduate
and adapt to this right here and this
would be really good if someone wanted
to improve their metabolism if they have
stubborn weight it's actually great for
diabetics to actually help insulin
resistance so between you know two meals
and one meal is a good option now should
you go beyond this well if you do you
have to know what the heck you're doing
you have to have a nutritional reserve
because recently I had two different
people pass out because they did
extended fasting without building enough
reserves especially electrolytes so they
had low electrolytes one guy fell over
and passed out hit his nose another
person passed out because they didn't
have the amount of electrolytes through
the day so they just pretty much pushed
through just drank water nothing else
and they didn't have the nutrient
reserve that they needed to do this so I
don't recommend going beyond 23 hours
unless you know you're doing
and you build up your nutritional
reserves okay thanks for watching hey if
you enjoyed this video press subscribe
and I will definitely keep you updated